[Music]
you're turning 40 soon what is the
biggest lesson that you've learned over
the years what it like I feel like
you're the best version of yourself
right now yeah um I think it's important
to not forget about yourself that even
though you wear many hats you also have
to wear your own and make time for
yourself whether if that's you know
reading a book or going to the spa or
simply just sleeping or you know cooking
for yourself I think it's super
important and because we give out so
much energy we were such nurturing
creatures you know when we have children
and you have a household you have a
family and you also when you go to work
and if you're a boss and you have people
that look up to you and that depend on
you it's important that you nurture
yourself first so that that you can
continue to nurture others so yeah I do
that you have a favorite birthday gift
that you've gotten so far I think it was
just the birth of my three sons you know
it's so far it's been the most exciting
most challenging role I think I will
ever get to to play for the rest of my
life and and it's about just allowing
them to teach me how they want to be
treated so there's a lot of listening
that takes place besides talking you
know and and they drive you crazy just
have to exercise and stay fit because
you're constantly just running around
after one kid picking somebody up
somebody's rip their knee changing a
diaper it requires a lot of physical
energy and you can't really have that if
you're tired or you're exhausted or
you're depleted that's why I keep saying
it's good to take care of yourself tim
burton zoe saldana reflecting on her
biggest lesson since turning 40 and
taking on motherhood soon the actress
will reprise her role on the big screen
in the Avatar sequel
pshew I heard from James Cameron that
you rapped avatar two and three you're
finished with it tell us how we're gonna
pick up with the first sequel well in
the first movie you saw how humans were
invading this planet and taking
advantage of all its resources and kind
of doing the same thing that they had
done with Planet Earth that they're
doing now in Pandora
so the naught V which are the people
that live there aren't that happy about
it so they're gonna give them a run for
their money so obviously the saga is
going to continue in that form
but the message about trying to live in
synchrony study with mother nature I
feel like it's the biggest takeaway of
the whole avatar a series now are we
gonna break record so what are you
thinking from shooting the first two are
you breaking records again we already
did with Avengers infinity war I know
that it already passed it's two billion
dollar box-office mark and
congratulations Marvel and Disney yes
yes once again so I have the same hopes
for for avatar it all depends as long as
we make a good we do a good job and and
we give people an adventure that that
lingers in their hearts then then yeah
we do have the ability to break it on
the record
[Music]